[Applaudissements]
le cerveau c'est cet organe c'est
certainement l'organe le plus complexe
de l'univers une vingtaine de watts
comme un moteur
près de 100 milliards de nombreux
d'ailleurs et le mettre dans
l'ordinateur
ou en tout cas on a 100 milliards on est
tous d'accord que c'est l'organe le plus
complexe de l'univers je l'ai dit à
l'instant mais par rapport à un
ordinateur paradoxalement il est très
long par rapport à une calculette par
rapport à un processeur pourquoi parce
qu'il est en permanence sollicité
sollicité pour prendre des décisions
solliciter parce que on n'est pas loin
d'un centre commercial il y a des
stimuli pour une odeur et par rapport à
l'ordinateur qui est ici il est très
très très lent le serveur c'est tout le
temps tout le temps de manière donner
une logique au monde
ça c'est très pénible pour lui de ne pas
comprendre ce qu'il voit y compris quand
il voit un tour de magie mais le
problème l'autre versant c'est que c'est
très réducteur
est-ce que vous voyez ici
quatre ronds noirs d'accord ok 4 trous
noirs plein mais si j'enlève maintenant
quelques angles
qu'est-ce que vous voyez apparaître par
conséquent
nous sommes bien d'accord
est-ce que dans l'absolu le carré il
existe
non en fait ce que j'essaie de
d'illustrer par ce
cet exemple concret
c'est que le cerveau essaie de donner
une logique à ce qu'il voit et que ce
qu'il y avait il y a quelques instants
quatre ronds noirs a été remplacé par un
carré vous comprenez l'exemple
en quelques sortes notre cerveau il
essaie de résoudre en permanence des
essaie de donner une interprétation
cohérente au monde qui voit mais en fait
sous prétexte de créer une cohérence des
fois cette cohérence et cette réalité
qu'il nous donne à voir elle est fausse
je vais vous parler aussi de la cécité
d'attention la cécité c'est ne pas voir
et donc
de manière sous-jacente il y a des
lacunes et des contradictions on vient
de le voir à l'instant avec les deux
exemples du carré et des cercles alors
comment expliquer cela de manière
concrète
d'un point de vue physiologique d'un
point de vue anatomique
tout simplement déjà par le
fonctionnement de l'oeil en lui-même
ceci est une découpe d'oeil on va pas
rentrer on va pas rentrer en détail mais
regardez bien ici vous voyez le
filet bleu ici qui a mon doigt c'est la
fovéa le nom est ici également alors la
fauvia c'est une zone dans la rétine
qui est très importante et c'est la
partie centrale en fait de la rétine
et comme vous voyez sur le faisceau
notre œil n'est capable de voir que
droit comme quand je regarde
actuellement
ce qui veut dire que si je veux me
déplace de quelques degrés seulement
mon cerveau n'est plus capable de voir
au-delà de quelques degrés bien sûr si
je mets le stylo ici derrière je peux
pas le voir
un peu plus sur le côté mais plus je
m'éloigne de la périphérie moi je peux
voir ce qui bien sûr en magie et très
important et très utile vous avez tous
entendu parler du détournement
d'attention donc quand j'utilise la
fovéa
de manière directe pour parvenir à mes
c'est extrêmement
utile
et en plus de ça la fovéa autre
précision
donc c'est tout droit et en plus de ça
c'est en couleur c'est à dire au-delà de
la zone de la peau va ici
on voit le monde en noir et blanc donc
vous comprenez les limites et on voit
pas plus que là où on pose notre regard
par exemple je regarde Morgane ou
Charlotte
j'ai beaucoup de mal à avoir un peu plus
loin que le deuxième ou troisième rang
en quelques sortes ce qu'il faut bien
retenir c'est comme si vous étiez chez
vous et que vous voyez le monde à
travers une toute petite fenêtre
ce qui est très embêtant est-ce qu'il y
a un peu contradictoire parce que on est
tous persuadé avant d'assister à
souhaiter que c'est conférence que notre
cerveau on est très intelligent et qu'on
est capable de percevoir le monde à 360
degrés vous êtes déjà tous chez vous
regardez en face de votre immeuble et
c'est la nuit c'est à peine
et on voit notre propre reflet dans la
glace de la vitre de notre appartement
et en même temps on est capable de voir
au dehors de chez nous mais je pense que
vous serez tous d'accord c'est très
difficile de faire les deux choses en
même temps alors quelle est la solution
ma première conclusion c'est bien sûr on
l'a vu avec Pierre et en oeuvre dans la
magie on ne peut pas bien sûr faire les
deux choses en même temps d'un point de
vue anatomique donc faites le choix de
là où vous voulez porter votre attention
nous allons essayer de voir comment nous
allons vu que d'un point de vue visuel
nous avons nos propres limites avec la
fova avec l'anatomie mais nous avons
aussi des limites mentales
Robin je vais prendre ce tableau ici et
vous allez penser une ville
et on va voir que comme c'est assez
simple comme nous avons des systèmes le
système 1 c'est celui qui est le plus
rapide qui prend des décisions
immédiates donc je vais utiliser ce
système 1 pour essayer de décompter
Robin alors vous avez votre vie en tête
ok ceci étant une sorte de globe
terrestre en tout cas c'est un rond et
je vais dire Est-Ouest Est Ouest Est
Ouest regardez moi pour c'est à votre
ville
je dirais qu'elle est plutôt à l'ouest
regardez moi Nord-Sud se rétractée
très bien donc je sais qu'elle est dans
cette périphérie
[Musique]
vous allez penser à la dernière lettre
de votre ville c'est bon
vous allez penser
à un fruit qui commence par cette lettre
est-ce que vous avez un fruit très bien
je me tourne vous voyez pas est-ce que
tout le monde arrive à lire au fond le
fruit
que vous avez choisi
merci
alors
est-ce que c'est un encours un nom
composé un nombre je vois ok j'ai une
petite idée de quel est le nom de la
ville vous avez rien vous avez vu que
Robin n'a rien prononcé depuis le début
parfait tout le monde voit jusqu'au fond
le nom de la ville Robin
vous avez choisi une ville dans votre
tête vous n'avez rien dit quasiment
depuis le début est-ce que je pouvais
donner le nom de la ville que vous avez
choisi
[Applaudissements]
encore un peu plus Guillaume est-ce que
tu peux mettre le tableau au milieu
j'arrive romain est-ce que vous acceptez
de faire une autre expérience avec moi
ok alors ceci je sais pas si on a qui
joue parmi vous c'est le Lexicon est-ce
qu'il y en a qui connaissent le Lexicon
dans la salle c'est un jeu de très vieux
qui date des années 30 et qui présente
des lettres est-ce que vous pouvez
montrer Robin
à quoi ressemble le Lexicon ce sont des
lettres et vérifier par la même occasion
ce sont des lettres très différentes
est-ce que vous avez des lettres très
différentes est-ce que vous pouvez
mélanger
très bien vous allez me donner le jeu et
ce que je vais vous demander Robin je
vais vous faire travailler vous allez
mettre 12 vous allez bien mélanger très
bien vous allez mettre les 12 premières
lettres de votre puisque maintenant le
mélange est au hasard on est d'accord
vous allez mettre les 12 premières
lettres sur le tableau en mettant une
lettre avec un aimant ça vous va allez
c'est parti
je vous donne une lettre et vous mettez
un aimant
voilà
très bien encore
une fois deux fois
trois fois donc là on en est la
troisième lettre quatrième lettre
cinquième lettre
sixième lettre et on va faire une autre
colonne
encore
parfait donc là maintenant nous avons
une colonne de 12 Robin
est-ce que vous pouvez me montrer une
colonne celle que vous voulez
ici très bien donc ça c'est celle là
donc on a on élimine toute cette
OK
lettre au hasard je ne les connais pas
montrez-moi une des deux lettres
celle-ci alors regardez la vers vous
prenez la vers vous
c'est bon vous la regardez vous la
regardez avec vous
c'est bon
vous pouvez la mettre dans la poche si
vous voulez
très bien Robin je ne connais pas la
lettre est-ce que vous pouvez penser à
tout simplement un instrument de musique
qui commence par cette lettre
oui ok je vais marquer quelque chose
c'est bon tout le monde voit pour la
première fois Robin est-ce que dire
qu'elle est l'instrument de musique que
vous avez choisi
merci beaucoup
et ce qui est très étrange c'est que
Robin a mélangé les cartes pourtant si
on retourne l'esprit m'aider à retourner
les cartes une à une
voilà très bien je vous laisse le faire
vous-même un
ensuite un
suspense c'est comme au millionnaire
ça vous dit comment ça vous dire quelque
chose encore
et si on retourne et vous mettez la
lettre X s'il vous plaît à la fin voilà
corps
pour le prononcer tous ensemble cortex
merci beaucoup
pour moi les mots ont une grande
importance
l'illusion de libre arbitre c'est le
titre de ce deuxième chapitre
puisque
je donne l'illusion au spectateur qu'il
a le libre arbitre de choisir un mot de
conseil à une ville ou de penser à des
lettres
simplement comme je vous le disais il y
a quelques instants en tant que
journaliste les mots ont une grande
importance
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 mots quasiment pour
désigner la même chose est-ce que vous
avez eu le sentiment que Robin avait le
libre choix lever la main si vous pensez
que regarder le libre choix
pourtant je l'ai emmené exactement vous
le voyez bien avec le mot cortex vous le
voyez bien le xylophone vous le voyez
bien avec New York exactement où je l'ai
emmené comment j'ai procédé tout
simplement bien sûr mon métier repose
sur le pilier c'est le secret mais
j'utilise les biais cognitifs donc les
biens cognitifs ce sont des failles de
notre cerveau couplé au système 1 et
système 2 c'est à dire notamment le
système puisque en fait le système 1 les
plus rapides
désignez montrez prendre choisir retenir
préféré si je dis à Robin de me désigner
une carte qu'est-ce qui serait passé si
on revient à la situation initiale où il
avait le choix entre deux colonnes je
voulais absolument une choisisse cette
colonne là quoi qu'il en soit je lui ai
demandé de désigner une carte ou une
colonne je n'ai jamais dit jamais jamais
choisissez une colonne j'aurais très
bien pu lui dire prenez montrer
préféré
et comme je procède par défaut c'est à
dire que même s'il m'avait dit
désigner moi une colonne
celle là on va vous donner à l'issue de
la première expérience l'information
qu'on retenait celle-là c'est de dire
que quel que soit le choix et Robin
avait fait
je l'emmenais où je voulais et bien sûr
faut faire attention à ça tous les jours
vous êtes confronté à tous les cognitifs
c'est
malheureusement ou à nos dépens
notamment pour les publicités c'est très
utilise c'est bien cognitif tous les
jours en vous donnant l'illusion vous
avez le choix au restaurant que vous
avez le choix de prendre telle ou tel
compagnie c'est un outil très puissant
alors quelques quelle sera
ma conclusion par rapport à donc des
pieds des biais cognitifs et des billets
visuels d'un point de vue donc deux
grands dangers puisque notre corps d'une
chatte d'une certaine d'un point de vue
anatomique avec notre œil et nous trahi
aussi dans nos prises décisions
quelle conclusion on peut en tirer c'est
que globalement il faut plutôt être dans
un temps long réfléchir plutôt qu'agir
on vous voit toujours mieux la situation
avec du recul vous avez compris qu'avec
le système 1 décision rapide que moi
j'utilise en tant que magicien je
j'essaie de vous emmener et donc si vous
l'aviez pris du recul avec le système 2
vous auriez peut-être pris une toute
autre décision mon slogan attention
illusion rime avec intuition une
intuition c'est le système 1 le choix 1
le plus rapide une fois de plus si vous
prenez du recul sur la situation
et si vous n'avez pas
d'intuition ou en tout cas il faut s'en
méfier de ces intuitions
autre solution et ça sera la dernière
c'est de réancrire
la problématique la voir non pas de
manière binaire est-ce que j'ai choisi
une glace à la vanille ou une glace à la
fraise non est-ce que je choisis est-ce
que je peux choisir une glace
et si on déplace notre centre de gravité
on verra les choses
différemment donc utilisez ça
professionnel utilisez ça également
dans votre vie quotidienne avec vos
proches la reformulation et énergie sa
vision c'est aussi voir sa vie d'un
nouvel angle merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]